hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
test and differentiate covet 19 flew a b
and rsv with one assay my name is
gabriel o'rama of thermo fisher
scientific and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more about their coven 19 influenza and
rsv testing solutions please visit
thermofisher.com
covid flu rsv
this presentation includes four
questions that will appear on screen two
will appear now and two will appear at
the end of the presentation before the q
a session
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send we'll answer as many
as we can
for at the end of the presentation you
may also submit any technical issues
here if we if you have trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
now i'd like to welcome our speakers
jelena fanstra senior manager of global
communications and peter freebie senior
manager of clinical applications jelena
and peter work at thermo fisher
scientific within genetic testing
solutions
the unit responsible for bringing one of
the first covet 19 assays to market as
part of the response to the pandemic
this presentation will begin with an
overview of the respiratory virus
ecosystem and will then switch to the
workflow of our thermo fisher's covet 19
flu ab rsv combo kit
you can find a shortened version of the
workflow and other collaterals related
to the product in the application note
hosted in the studio feel free to
download at takeover study
with that out of the way let's pass the
microphone to jelena fiendstra jelena
you may now begin with your presentation
hello thank you so much for the kind
introduction today i will talk about why
it is important to detect and
discriminate the influenza
inp sarskov ii and respiratory synthetic
virus during flu season
a seasonal flu is a contagious
respiratory illness caused by influenza
viruses that circulate in all parts of
the world
in the northern hemisphere the flu
season typically occurs in the colder
months of the year and the peak in the
number of infections usually happens
between december and february
depending on the year for example in the
u.s between 3 and 11 of the entire
population suffers from a symptomatic
flu infection but a large proportion of
infected individuals are actually
asymptomatic
and here are some statistics regarding
the number of cases hospitalizations and
deaths resulting from flu each year um
in the u.s
seasonal flu leads to 140 to 810 000
hospitalizations and 12 to 61 000 deaths
per year in the us and these numbers are
fairly similar in the eu or the european
economic area with estimated 4 to 50
million cases and up to 70 000 deaths
per year
um coronavirus disease 2019 or covet 19
is an infectious respiratory disease
caused by a normal corona virus starts
cop2 that emerged at the end of
2019 in buchanan china and on march 11
last year the who had declared the
status quo to outbreak as a global
pandemic by today more than
228 million cases have been confirmed
with over four and a half million people
who died of covet 19. and this graph on
the right represents the number of
confirmed cases per week in each part of
the world from the beginning of the
pandemic to mid-september 2021 and on
the left you can also see the total
number of cases for each region
now
let's look at the causative agents of
these two diseases so the seasonal flu
is caused by implants a and b viruses
and these viruses belong to the orthomic
severity family of rna viruses and there
are in fact four types of influenza
viruses a b c and d but it is in fact
the a and b which are responsible for
the seasonal flow infections
the influenza c infections generally
cause mild illness and are not thought
to be involved in the season of flow
epidemics and influenza d viruses
actually infect cattle and are not
thought to cause illness in people
so the genome of influenza viruses is
rna and it consists of eight negative
single strands so it's a segmented
genome and the structure of the viral
particle is actually represented in the
image here and you can see two proteins
on the surface of the implants of
viruses which are particularly important
and these are the hemagglutinin which is
shown here in blue and neuraminidase
which is shown in red
and the hemagglutinin binds to the
cellic acid which serves as a receptor
on the surface of respiratory epithelial
cells and enables the virus to enter the
cells and the neuraminidase on the other
hand facilitates the release of the
viral particles from the infected cells
and their spread
on the other hand if we look at you know
the covet 19
it is caused by sars cop2 and while
sarskova ii is also an rna virus like
the influenza viruses
it belongs to a different family so
these are coronaviruses the genome of
the sarskov2 virus is not segmented so
it is a single positive strand of rna
and there is only one strain of the
virus with different viral variants
and if we look at the structure of the
viral particle
we can see that the surface of the virus
is covered mainly in the so-called s or
the spike protein which binds to the
ace2 receptor on human cells and enables
the virus to infect them
so
as i mentioned in the previous slide
the styroscopy 2 virus
is a single strain while influenza a and
b have various subtypes so in case of
influenza a the subtypes are defined by
the two surface proteins that i already
mentioned the neuraminidase and the
hemoglobin
and there are 11 types of neuraminidase
and 18 types of hemagglutinin which
potentially uh gives
198 types of influenzae viruses however
only 131 types have been detected in
nature so far
and the currently circulating uh
subtypes of influenza a are the h1n1 and
the h3n2
the h1n1 is related to the 2009 swine
flu pandemic
um the influenza b virus has two
lineages yamagata and victoria and
normally displays a slower change of
genetic and antigenic features compared
to influenzae
there was a misconception that the flu b
viruses cause a milder disease but since
then several studies have shown that the
influence of d can cause equally severe
disease as influenza a
and currently the seasonal influenza is
a mix of influenza a h1n1 a
h3n2 and the two b lineages
in this graph on the right you can see
the surveillance data from the previous
five years
and you can see that the percentage of
each of the contributing influencer
subtypes varies per year and also that
you know in some years some subtypes
will appear earlier or later than the
others
um so let's look at how seasonal flu and
covet 19 are transmitted and how does
the incubation time and clinical
presentation compare
so both flue and covid19 are easily
transmitted through direct contact and
droplets but also indirect spread and
aerosols play a role in spreading the
viral particles
kovite 19 is considered to be more
contagious and also more super spreaders
have been observed with covet 19.
and the person infected with the virus
is usually contagious one day before the
onset of symptoms and up to one week
after the symptom starts in case of flu
but in case of covet 19 one can be
infectious two days before the symptoms
appear and at least 10 days after so in
fact people are contagious over a longer
period of time in case of covet 19.
um the symptom onset usually occurs in
case of flu one to four days upon an
infection so quicker while for cove the
incubation can take up to 14 days
um and one thing that both viruses have
in common is that infected people can be
asymptomatic or have a mild moderate or
severe disease
now once a patient gets symptoms of a
respiratory illness
how do we actually know if it is coveted
or flu and the fact is that um covet 19
and influenza cannot be differentiated
based on symptoms only
um if we look at the clinical
presentation usually a patient will have
chills fever
sore throat headache runny nose
general
you know tiredness
and in children very common are vomiting
and diarrhea but these symptoms are
common for both diseases
now of course there are also some
differences um so for example a loss or
alteration of smell and taste has been
associated with covid19
and also patients suffering from covet
have been shown to have um sometimes
cytokine storm or in certain cases some
blood clots and in children the
multi-system inflammatory syndrome has
been described
on the other hand patients suffering
from flu more often get a secondary
bacterial infection and also younger
children are at a higher risk of
complications in case of flu than covet
so um actually in case of both coveted
and flu a certain proportion of patients
will develop a severe disease uh which
is then characterized by pneumonia
acute respiratory distress syndrome and
so on and in particular people with
chronic conditions such as diabetes or
cardiovascular disease may suffer from
complications
if they are the risk group together with
the people 65 years and older
but the fact of the matter is that if
one wants to differentiate whether a
patient presenting with these symptoms
has flu or influenza
testing needs to be performed in order
to confirm the diagnosis
so um the cdc has actually developed
recommendations on testing strategy when
sars cov2 and implants are called
circulating so basically if a patient
comes in with symptoms of an acute
respiratory illness
and the patient requires hospitalization
or is a resident of a nursing home for
example um it is recommended that the
multiplex nucleic acid detection essay
for influenza a b and stars code 2 is
performed if available
of course the viruses can also be tested
individually but the multiplex test can
offer faster results
and if the patients do not require
hospitalization it is recommended that
they get tested by pcr for stars cover 2
and that the test for influenza is also
performed either as a single test or in
a multiplex essay when available if the
results will influence the clinical
management or steps taken to control the
spread of the infection
now what is very important to remember
and is particularly highlighted in the
cbc testing recommendations is that the
co-infections of influenza and sars cov2
can occur and do occur and
um that if we do a single test for call
it first for example and it is positive
that does not automatically exclude
influencer infection in the same
individual and this is the exact reason
why the multiplex testing is recommended
and especially in hospitalized patients
or nursing home residents in order to
prevent cross infection in these
settings as patients having covet only
must of course be separated from
patients that are suffering from a
co-infection with flu
so um
in cases of mild illness of both covet
and flu
the treatment is mainly focused on
symptom management and includes
bad rest isolation avoiding contact with
other people
in cases with severe disease or in
people at high risk of complications
supportive medical care is given to
manage symptoms and prevent
complications
or manage them
however treatment strategies in all
other cases are different for covid and
flu and of course the treatment
algorithms
may vary a little bit by country and
local recommendations
but this is the sort of general overview
so outpatients at high risk of disease
progression with kovid 19
can receive antistarts co2 monoclonal
antibodies
and in hospitalized cases on
supplemental oxygen remdevier
dexamethasone or both agents are given
to patients
in patients who require oxygen delivery
through a high flow device or
ventilation in addition to dexamethasone
varicity or tonsillitum are applied
and treatment decision for covid19
actually does not depend on the viral
variant with which the patient is
infected
in cases with flu antiviral drugs have
been shown to have the best clinical
benefit if given in the first 48 hours
of the symptom onset which is an
additional reason why testing can that
can enable a quick and precise result is
essential
uh there are several approved drugs for
flu such as neuraminidase inhibitors
which are osceltamivir and tsunamivir
but also
um acidic and the nucleus inhibitor
paloxavir
in addition antibiotics are prescribed
for secondary bacterial infections which
we already mentioned are more common in
cases of flu
the virus type or subtypes actually do
not influence the treatment decisions
so even though clinically based on
symptoms only the two diseases are very
similar the clinical management of
patients is very different and correct
diagnosis is very important in order to
achieve uh better outcomes
now one thing that both influenza
viruses and sars copy 2 have in common
is that they mutate and in the case of
influenza virus there are two types of
changes that are happening um the
so-called antigenic drift which
represents minor changes to the genome
and then antigenic shift which usually
happens when one segment of the genome
is replaced by a segment from a
different influenza virus and this
usually happens in animals and is the
way how strains that can give rise to
flu pandemics arise
so as only influenza a viruses have
animal reservoirs they are the only ones
that can actually give rise to a
pandemic
there were three pandemics of flu in the
20th century with the latest one in 2009
in which case the genes from north
american swine eurasian swine human and
bird flu were combined
in the a h1n1 pdm09 virus
on the other hand sarskovi two virus
accumulates mutations in its genome
most of which are actually affecting the
s protein which is the surface protein
and the emerging variants that contain a
particular set of mutations are
classified based on the risk they pose
for the public health
as variants of interest variants of
concern and variance of high consequence
at the moment there are five variants of
concern circulating which are referred
to as alpha beta gamma and delta plus
the alpha variant with the e484k
mutation
and some of the variants share these key
mutations relevant to the function of
the virus
how do we prevent the spread of covet
and flu
so in both cases personal protective
measures are recommended
including hand washing avoiding to touch
your face nose or mouth or contact with
infected individuals and during the
covet 19 pandemic countries have
implemented additional strict public
health measures
prior to the availability of the vaccine
including social distancing travel bans
etc
now of course vaccinations play a major
role in preventing disease and for flu
annual vaccination is recommended for
risk groups and as we have seen the
viruses mutate and different subtypes
may be present each year and so the flu
vaccines are annually updated based on
the surveillance data on influenza
viruses from the previous flu season and
normally because this is sometimes not
the best predictor of which subtypes
will be circulating next year the flu
vaccine efficacy is reducing the risk of
low illness varies between 40 and 60
percent
and several vaccines are available in
the eu the most common are trivalent or
quadruple and injected inactivated
influenza vaccines
the 19 vaccines have been developed in
really record time in 2020 as you
already know and currently there are
four different vaccines that have been
uh authorized for use in europe by the
european medicines agency and the
current recommendation is to vaccinate
everyone 18 years and older with two
vaccines also authorized for children 12
years and older and the vaccines are
based either on rna technology or viral
vectors and although stars called it to
mutate it is still unclear whether
updates to the vaccines will be needed
due to novel emerging viral variants
several currently circulating variants
of concern are associated with slightly
reduced efficacy of the currently
available vaccines but so far it is
considered that the vaccine efficacy is
high
now
besides covet and flu there are of
course other respiratory viruses which
can cause similar symptoms and today i
would just like to mention the
respiratory synthetic virus of the rsv
as this is one of the leading causes of
respiratory disease globally and also
shows seasonal activity similarly to flu
in autumn and winter months
and actually the symptoms are usually
cough runny nose fever loss of appetite
and also severe disease may develop
causing pneumonia or bronchiolitis
so as you can see these symptoms are
actually very very similar or
overlapping with a flu and call it 19.
the risk groups for severe disease are
actually young infants and older adults
or people with chronic diseases or weak
immune system
rsv is estimated to lead to around 60
000 hospitalizations in kids younger
than five and more than 170 000
hospitalizations in adults over 65 years
of age annually with 14 000 deaths among
the adults 65 years and older for
example in the united states
and the treatment is focused mainly on
symptom management while vaccines for
rsv are in development
so you can immediately see that there
are a lot of similarities in clinical
presentation of rsv
to call with 19 and flu
and
on this slide i would like to show you
some of the surveillance data from the
eu
where you can see for example on the
upper panel um how the rsv or the
seasonal activity of rsv
in the past couple of years with peak of
infections occurring usually in the last
or the first week of the year during the
winter
and on the grass below you can see
seasonal flu which is active in the same
period of the year what we refer to as
the flu season
but the peak of infection varies from
december to march and for example in the
last 12 years which are shown on this
slide or on this graph um the peak was
most often seen in february so in weeks
five to seven
but what i want to bring your attention
to is this last year which is
highlighted in pink where you can see
that the data initially showed that
actually there was no fluoresce v
circulating during the usual
flu season
however then cases started to peak at
week 11 for flu and week 13 for rsv
which is much later than usual
and this timing is very relevant um with
regard to the public health measures
that were in place related to the kovite
19 pademic that i will talk about in the
next slide
as the kovite 19 vaccination is
progressing worldwide we can see that
some countries like the united arab
emirates spain or portugal
have managed already to fully vaccinate
80 percent or more of their population
but worldwide only 42 percent of people
have received a single dose and actually
only 30 percent have been fully
vaccinated
um and of course the rate of vaccination
has had an impact on the public health
measure stringency shown in these graphs
so if you look here the dark red color
corresponds to high stringency meaning
social distancing travel bands mask
wearing etc
and you can see that many countries
still had strict measures in place for
example in february this year but then
as the vaccination for kovite 19
progressed most of the countries were
starting to ease the restrictions in
february or march and this exactly
correspond to the seven peak in cases of
flu and rsv that i have shown you a
couple of slides earlier
so it is actually clear that all the
public health measures that were put in
place for covid 19 were in fact very
efficient in preventing the spread of
other respiratory viruses like flu or
rsv
but as the restrictions are easing it is
expected that the surge in cases of flu
and rsv might occur as already seen in
some parts of the world
now uh in fact the academy of medical
sciences in the united kingdom and also
who have published reports
looking ahead to winter 2021 22 and
beyond where they state that higher
activity of influenza and rsv viruses is
anticipated and that eating of social
distancing and other measures may lead
to surging infections and in addition we
have to consider that there is a
decreased population immunity due to
non-pharmaceutical intervention and
lower exposure to influenza and rsv in
the previous season which might also
play a role
of course there is also limited data
available for influenza strains in the
previous season for vaccine design as we
thought that there were not so many flu
cases which of course increases the
likelihood of influenza vaccine mismatch
for the upcoming season
and um finally i would like to conclude
my talk with the two statements on
testing recommendations coming from the
european center for disease control
and the academy of medical sciences in
the uk
so um all patients with acute
respiratory symptoms in hospitals and
other health care settings and all
specimens from sentimental primary case
surveillance
should be tested for both sarcoido and
influenza during the influenza season to
monitor incidents and trends over time
and then given overlapping symptoms
routine multi-pathogen testing for
starch cove 2 influenza and possibly
other respiratory infections is
important for surveillance treatment
decisions such as timely use of
antivirals for influenza
minimizing isolation times and avoiding
and reducing rates of transmission we
strongly support multiplex testing
so um with this i would like to thank
you for your attention and i'm happy to
hand over to peter friebe who will
present the testing solutions tamo
fisher scientific has developed to
enable the laboratory professionals to
meet the challenges of the upcoming flu
season thank you
thank you elena for this excellent and
very informative overview
on the importance of detecting and
differentiating
through ab rsv and sas corner virus 2
during the next flu season
in the second half of this webinar i
want to introduce you to the tagpass
covet 19 flueab rc combo kit which is
some official scientific solution to
meet the demand for respiratory testing
during the next flu season
my name is peter frieber and i'm a
senior manager for clinical application
and marketing support
the second half of this webinar will be
clustered into our brief introduction to
thermo fisher scientific the company i
will then highlight the attack path
covered 19 fluid a b rsv combo kit and
will focus on the workflow the
turnaround time and the performance of
the kit
and at the very end i will give you a
brief introduction into our new a b
platinum instrument service plan
thermo fischer scientific is the global
leader in covet 19 testing solutions
over 50 percent of all covet 19 testing
performed is using thermofisher
technology
we were able to upscale covet 19 test
manufacturing to over 20 million tests
per week
and if need be we can even increase this
capacity
we also offer a secured supply chain to
reliable meet global testing demands of
all the consumables test kits
instruments needed for our clients to
test to perform all the tests needed
we can do so because thermo fisher
scientific is vertically integrated and
all the companies that are listed on top
of this slide are part of thermo fisher
scientific
we also offer our 24 7 service and
support on all our consumables
instruments and the software
and with that i want to introduce you to
the tagpath covered 19 flu a b rsv combo
kit which is ce ivd marked and for in
vitro diagnostic use
the tagbus covet 19 flow abrc combo kit
is an all-in-one c ivd rt-pcr raspberry
test designed to increase lab efficiency
it can in a single test
detect and differentiate between sas
corona voice 2 influenza a b
and rsv
and it can also detect co-infections
it is affordable and scalable
the workflow allows to increase testing
throughput therefore
increasing lab
efficiency it is a highly sensitive and
specific detection kit with a very
robust performance to detect sas corner
wires to flue a b and rsv
and our attack pass covert 19 flow ab
rsv combo kit also comes with our
pathogen interpretive software that will
automatically validate each test run and
create a report for each of the specimen
tested
the workflow of the tagpath covert 19
flow abrc combo kit is shown on this
slide
i will go to
over each of the steps shown on this
slide in more detail in my next slides
but i want to start giving you a general
overview
a lab will first receive the samples the
samples then need to be prepped the
real-time pcr is prepared and run
and then the interpretive software will
calculate the results and create a
report
sample types that are supported by the
kit are nasopharyngeal swabs
once the samples are received by the lab
they need to be
prepared we do recommend to use our
magmax viral pathogen 2 nucleic acid
isolation kit in combination with our
automated kingfisher flags purification
system for streamlined sample
preparation
please note that before preparation of
the sample the ms2 bacteriophage is
added to each specimen
ms2 bacteriophage will act as a
extraction and process control for each
sample
once samples are prepared the real-time
pcr is set up on our 96 well plate using
the tagpass covet 19 flow abrc combo kit
the pcr is run on the 7500 fast
real-time pcr system
once the run is finished the
interpretive software the pathogen
interpreter software will automatically
interpret test result it also performs a
quality control on all the controls on
the plate which is at least one positive
control one negative control and the ms2
bacteriophage process control in each
sample
the pathogen interpretive software will
also generate an interpretive report for
each of the specimen included in the
test
the software also allows to export the
results in a file that is compatible
with your lims or list system available
in your laboratory
the
pathogen interpretive software can be
installed on any qualified computer it
can be co-installed on a computer that
already runs our covet 19 interpreter
software
and the pathogen interpretive software
supports analyzes of data sets from
multiple qpcr instruments that can be
sent seamlessly over network to the
computer that has a pathogen
interpretive software installed
the user interface of the pathogen
interpreter software is very user
friendly
it is shown here on this slide
to the right upper corner it will
display the 96 valve plate and the
samples that are included on the test
run
the samples are either markus or plus or
minus depending whether a virus was
detected or not and hovering over a well
will show the amplification plots to the
left of the respective targets on the
bottom part of the user interface you
can also see a table with all the
samples tested and the results for each
of the sample
again the results can be exported in a
lis lims compatible file or you can
export it in our interpretive report
the interpretive report
will
include information about the run itself
it includes information about the date
of the run or the time of the run and
the instrument used to perform the run
it
includes information about the positive
and negative control
and then it includes the results for
each of the specimen tested and it will
highlight whether or not a virus was
detected in each specimen
now that i have introduced you to the
workflow i also want to give you an
overview of of the turnaround time to
perform the essay
the overall turnaround time from sample
to result is about three hours
it takes roughly 45 minutes to receive
94 samples that can be tested on a 96
6 well plate
please keep in mind that one well is
dedicated to a positive and one well is
dedicated to a negative control
sample prep if carried out with our
kingfisher flex a system takes only 25
minutes for a 96 well plate
preparing the pcr takes about 30 minutes
and running the pcr takes 82 minutes
and the report is ready within five
minutes using our pathogen interpretive
software
to perform the pcr from setup running
the pcr and getting the result only
takes about 2 hours
as elena already mentioned the next flu
season might be a more severe one
it might become necessary for laboratory
to increase throughput of testing
the tagpath covert 19th flu abrc combo
kit is designed to allow maximizing
throughput by staggering
batches of samples as it's indicated on
this slide
the example on this slide uses a
laboratory that is equipped with a kink
with one kingfisher flags two rt pcr
system and it uses two full-time
employees per eight hour shift
and that allows to run up to 2700 tests
per 24-hour day
you can see in dark blue the
staggering of a batch of samples
that starts with receiving the samples
by the first employee
once the samples are received they are
transferred into the kingfisher flex for
automated sample purification
once purified the second employee
prepares the pcr and starts the pcr run
at that point the first employee is
already receiving the second batch of
samples and transferring the second
batch of samples into the kingfisher
flags
once the second batch of samples is
provided by the kingfisher flags this
second employee will start preparing the
pcr and run the pcr
this kind of staggering allows to
maximize the throughput and as mentioned
earlier uh it allows up to 2700 tests
per 24 hour a day
i now want to introduce you to the
performance of the tagpass covered 19
fluid a b rsv combo kit
i want to start with the limit of
detection which is expressed as either
tissue culture infectious dose 50 pml
or to simplify as genome copy
equivalence pml
for soft coronavirus 2 the limit of
detection is 50 genome copy equivalence
pml or short gce per ml
for influencer a b the limit of
detection varies between 350 and
1250 gce pml and that depends on which
strain is tested
for rsvab the limit of detection is 200
gce pml
we also performed
lab testing with different strains
for influenza a and influenza b
for influenza a we tested 10 different
isolates
focusing on the predicted dominant
strain for the next flu season which is
the h1n1 and the h3n2
for influencer b we tested five
five isolates
including the jammer garter and the
victoria line
we tested all the samples at a
concentration that is very close to the
limit of detection and all isolates were
tested in triplicates
the tagpath covert 19 flow a b rc combo
kit detected
the virus and oil samples tested
we also performed wet lab testing for
rsv we had tested we tested three
subtypes we tested three isolates for
subtype a and three isolates for subtype
b
again the test were carried out
with a concentration that is very close
to the limit of detection
and the checkpost covered 19 fluid a b
rsv combo kit that has detected this the
virus and oil samples tested
also performed cross reactivity tests to
ensure that the tagpass covet 19 floor
absd combo kit is highly specific to
corona virus 2 fluid ab and rsb
we tested all the infectious pathogens
shown on this slide and we did not
detect any cross reactivity
the tukpas covered 19 flu a brc combo
kit is a multiplex assay meaning it can
detect as we flew and sas coroner virus2
in the same sample it can also detect
co-infection
and to ensure that there is no
competence competitive interference we
performed a study in which we tested
samples that were spiked with two
viruses
one at a very high titer and one at a
very low titre
to the left you see the results of
samples we tested that were spiked with
a very high flue titer
and that had a very low titre of sas
coronavirus 2 a title that is close to
the limit of detection
as you can see by the amplification
plots shown on this slide
the as it detected the flu sam the flu
target in all samples which is shown
with the red amplification curve on the
left amplification plot
it also detected this corner virus ii
shown here with the green amplification
plot and labeled core with low
additionally it
detected the ms2 bacteriophage process
control
rsv was not detected in the sample
because it was not present in the sample
on the right hand side you see the
amplification plot for samples that were
spiked with a high title of rsv
and that had a very low titre of
influenza close to the limit of
detection
and again the acid detected influencer
at the low titra even in the presence of
a high tita rsv co-infected
we also performed a clinical study using
retrospective samples
the clinical study was carried out with
the tuckpass covered 19 fluid a b rsv
combo kit and a comparator for either
corner virus 2 influenza a b and or rsv
a b
shown on this slide are the positive
percentage agreement and the negative
percent agreement
just as a reminder the positive percent
agreement reflects the percentage of
samples that tested positive with the
tagpath covert 19 fluid ab rsv combo kit
and that also tested
positive with the comparator
whereas the negative percent agreement
reflects the percentage of samples that
tested negative with the tagpath covert
19th floor a b rsv combo kit and that
they also tested negative with the
comparator for the respective target
the positive percent agreement for sas
coronavirus 2 influenza a b rsvlb is
over
98
in case of influenza a b it is a hundred
percent
the negative percentage agreement for
rsv a b is about 93
for influenza a b it's between 60
69 and uh
96 and 97 percent and for star score now
is two it's a hundred percent
although a c ibd marked
nvidia diagnostic device does not have a
guideline which what percentage numbers
needs to be hit the us fda actually
provides that's kind of a guideline and
the percentages shown on this slide
exceed the requirements for the u.s fda
and overall demonstrate the excellent
clinical performance of the tagpath
covert 19th floor abrc combo kit
with that i want to summarize the
tagpass covert 19th floor a b rsv combo
kit targets last coronavirus 2 influenza
ab and rsvab
it can detect and differentiate between
all those three viruses in one sample
it can also detect co-infections
it uses the ms2 bacteriophage as an
internal process control
a positive control is included in the
kit
it uses nasopharyngeal swabs as a proved
sample
type we do recommend
the magmax wire opacity and nucleic acid
isolation kit in combination with our it
automated kingfisher flex purification
system for sample preparation
the approved return pcr system is our
7500 fast real-time pcr instrument
the turnaround time from sample to
result is about three hours and from
extracted rna to result is just under
two hours
the combo kit comes with our pathogen
interpretive software that will
automatically validate each run and
prepare a report for each of the
specimen included in the test
the tuckpass covert 19 fluid rsv combo
kit is c ivd marked and for in vitro
diagnostic use
if you are interested in our attackpass
covert 19 flow ab rsv combo kit you can
go through thermofisher.com
covet 19 flu rsv to find more about the
kit itself and to also find the ordering
number which is a49867
we currently offer the tagpass covert 19
flue abrc combo kit in a thousand
reaction format
and the kit includes all primer and
probes for the detection of the sas
coronavirus ii flu abrsv and the
internal
process control ms2 bacteriophage the
process control is also included in the
kit
it also includes the positive control
and a positive control dilution buffer
and it does include the tagpath one step
multi mic multiplex master mix which
includes the enzyme for the reverse
transcriptase pcr
last but not least i also want to
introduce you to the ab platinum service
plan
the eb platinum service plan is offered
to our ce ivd corporate 19 customers and
it covers qpc iron kingfisher system
we do
offer a 98 uptime guarantee of course
terms and condition apply
the ab platinum offering includes a
qualification system
each system is qualified post service
and repairs
it offers a priority technical support
that is available 24 7
year round that includes weekends
it also offers a rapid onsite response a
guaranteed next business day onsite
response
it includes a 2 hour remote field
application specialist consultation
it also covers all plant maintenances as
required
it includes a comprehensive repair
coverage it's an all-inclusive repair
and also a digital remote support
it covers our kingfisher flex
purification system and it covers our
quant studio 7 in 380 for well format it
covers our quant studio 5 in 96 well
n384 well format it covers our quant
studio 5dx it covers our 7500 fast dx
and it covers our 7500 and
7500 fast real-time pcr system
if you want to learn more about our ab
platinum support program please visit
thermofisher.com
uptime
please also note that the ab platinum is
only available in certain regions and
countries
with that i want to thank you for your
for attending this webinar and i open
the session for the q a
i see a question in the chat how can i
order the kit
as i've mentioned that is very easy you
can just go to thermofisher.com
covet flu rsv and request a quote and we
will follow up with you
all right thank you so much peter
it looks like our next question is
um how common are co-infections of covid
and flu
so let me take that one um thank you so
um yeah that's actually a great question
and you know um
at the beginning of the pandemic there
were some reports for example there was
a paper reporting on around 300 patients
from wuhan in china
um that were in the hospital early in
the pandemic during january in february
2020 when the flu was still circulating
and they actually reported that around
half of the patients with covet had also
implanted a and around five to ten
percent of the patients also influenced
a b
um but then you know some of the reports
that came later
actually said that um kovis and fluke
infections
occur somewhere between half a percent
and and five percent of the cases um and
and for example you know um they despite
low circulation of rsv uh an article in
yama reported that actually also sars
kobe 2 and rsv coin sections also occur
and overall it seems to be the consensus
that you know rsv and influence a are
the commonest viruses to occur together
with with covet now you know most of
these studies were published when there
was this really
big drop in circulation of other
respiratory pathogens due to all these
measures that were taken to combat the
pandemic i am and you know with that
being said um the concerns really are
about the upcoming flu season you know
with the easing of the social distancing
and mask wearing and travel opening up
if the blue season this year looks
different um you know how will we
how will the coin sections look like and
therefore many of the agencies are
actually um recommending you know the
multiplex testing for for several
viruses
all right thank you so much elena our
next question
um let's see
can the covid flu rsv kit substitute the
covet only test
would you like me to repeat the question
peter would you like to take this one
oh i know i take it i'm sorry i
had some internet connectivity
uh yes our tag pass covert 19 flu abrsv
combo kit is intended to detect sas
corner virus 2.
it can also detect and differentiate
between influenza a b and r 3 in the
same way
and that makes our kit
a valuable multiplex
test or kit for the upcoming flu season
okay great thank you now our next
question here how is the severity of a
flu season defined
so yeah thank you maybe i can take this
one yeah so you know it really depends
um but for example the ctc has very
clear criteria um and usually the
severity of the flu season is
classified as low moderate high or very
high
normally the agencies would use the data
such as for example
percentage of patient visits to
outpatient clinics for an influencer
like illness or the rates of influenza
associated um hospitalization
then percentage of that uh resulting
from um influence or pneumonia that
occurred during each season and you know
normally the the flu season severity
depends on the viral subtypes which are
circulating um each year as i explained
so um there is really a big question
coming up ahead of the following season
you know what will be the subtypes and
um how severe will the flu season be
considering also this you know reduced
general immunity of the population
all right thank you so much
our next question how much sensitivity
is the kit
i will answer that so there's an
analytical sensitivity which is equal to
the limit of detection and the limit of
detection for south korean or rs2 is 50
genome copy equivalents per milliliter
for rsv it is 200 gc or genome copy
equivalence per milliliter and for fluid
is between 350 and 1250
and that depends on which strain is
tested
if the question is more related towards
a clinical sensitivity
we
express that as positive percent
agreement and it's over 98 for each of
the targets it's a hundred percent for
influenza a b
thank you so much peter
okay next question
um you mentioned a surge of rsv cases
were observed in other parts of the
world could you please elaborate on that
yeah so i mean as i said you know there
was really no activity of lou and rsv
during the usual winter months last year
and then suddenly in summer this year um
many countries have reported rsv
um
outbreaks um so for example in the you
know the in the us the cdc data showed
that the levels of rsv are actually back
to 2019
levels but you know at the different
time of the year so you know normally we
would see this peak in december uh but
now you know we saw a peak in august and
for example a public health england has
also reported data that there was a
surge of rsv infections during the 2021
summer so you know that seems to be the
trend in the northern hemisphere
all right thank you very much okay we've
got time for one more question
next question i would like um to ask is
is this kit more preferable to research
using or clinical diagnosis
so the trackpad covered 19 flu abrc
combo kit is ceivd marked and it is for
in vitro diagnostic use so it would be
for medical application
thank you so much peter and elena for
your time today to either of you have
any final final comments before we close
so yeah i would just like to thank peter
for this great overview um of the kit
and you know we are all concerned of
what lies ahead of us against uh you
know in the upcoming months so um yeah i
guess we are all working towards uh
being prepared the best way we can and
enabling the labs to um
um you know combat the upcoming flu
season in the culvert pandemic in the
best way possible so thank you for your
attention
all right well thank you both again for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
labruz and our sponsor thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
as a reminder questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by our speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time